hello everyone
welcome to this video tutorial on how to
become a sql developer by simplylearn
in this session we will learn who is the
sql developer
and what are the responsibilities in a
company then we will focus
on the skills required to become a
successful sql developer
we will see the expected average salary
in both u.s and india we will also
discuss
how to become a sql developer and look
at the top companies
hiring for sql developers so hey
everyone
i am abhisaya rahuja from simply learn
and welcome to this video
on how to become a sql developer but
before we begin
if you love watching tech videos
subscribe to our channel and hit the
bell icon to never miss an update
when going through some of the popular
job boards online
you would easily see sql developer is
one of the most demanding jobs
seek by companies as we all know today
companies collect vast volumes of data
and store it
in their own databases they want
professionals with a good understanding
of data
who can keep it safe and secure so
first we will understand who is a sql
developer
sql developer is a person who is
accountable
in creating and managing huge data
assets of a company
in other terms sql developer is a person
who can develop sql databases as well as
write and test code
let's understand this with the help of
an example
let's say we want to search a particular
product on amazon website
and amazon has stored all its data about
products in a database
now we will write the product name in
the search bar
and when we click on the search button
it will run a sql query
that fetches all the information about
the product and displays us
on the website so this is the basic task
done by a sql developer
now we will understand the
responsibilities of a sql developer
all databases have a structure and logic
behind how data is stored and retrieved
a sql developer designs the database
accordingly for businesses
that is called database modeling after
the database is created
and deployed it's the sql developer who
is responsible for fixing the general
issues of the database
sql developer should be well versed with
structured query language
to create optimized sql queries and
refines the existing ones
to extract information from the database
sql developers run several diagnostic
tests
to keep a check on the server and the
database
in order to understand how to organize
companies data
sql developers must communicate with
tactical and non-technical persons from
the business
and sql developer also gathers client
requirements and identifies the features
that the database owners want as data is
an asset to a company
sql developers backup and restore data
for the clients
they also perform tasks like data
management and data migration
that is if a company has stored all its
data on a local storage
and now it want its data to be stored in
a cloud storage
so the safe transmission of the data
from local storage to cloud storage
is known as data migration and that is
done by the sql developers
after knowing the responsibilities now
should look for skill set required to be
a good sql developer
one should have a good knowledge of sql
commands functions
joins and procedures let's have a look
at few commands
such as create drop alter and truncate
these commands come under data
definition language
we also have insert update and delete
commands
these commands come under data
manipulation language we have grant and
devop commands
these commands come under data control
language we also have commit
rollback and save point commands these
come under transaction control language
these are the basic commands a sql
developer should be familiar with
and a sql developer may have a little
command
on any one programming language you
don't have to be expert in programming
all you need is how to interface between
application and your database
for example you are using mysql and your
web application is based on php
then you should know how to connect your
application to the database
and how to issue queries how to fetch
results
and then how to display it to the users
one should have a good understanding
of various database management systems
such as
mysql microsoft access oracle
postgre sql dbase foxpro
sqlite ibm db2
libreoffice base mariadb and
microsoft sql server one should know
integration of databases with data
visualization software
such as power bi and tableau which helps
businesses
to make better decisions and give you an
add-on as a sql developer
once you develop critical thinking and
problem solving skills to create
optimized queries now we'll see how a
sql developer
is compensated in both united states and
india
in the united states sql developers draw
an
average salary of dollar 72 282 per
annum
in india the average salary of a sql
developer is
rupees 4 lakh 49532
now we'll see how person can become a
good sql developer
for that one should have a good command
on structured query language
and know how to interact with database
management system
and can issue queries to get the desired
result
earning industry recognized sql
developer certifications
such as microsoft certified professional
developer
mcpd or oracle pl sql
developer certified associate which
usually require a passing score on an
exam and it's important to accumulate
as much practical experience as possible
start by designing
creating and querying small databases
connected with
your hobbies and interests for example
your favorite music
videos or your personal finances this
will enable you to gain experience
test your knowledge and build your
project portfolio
which will be highly beneficial when you
start applying for your first full-time
position now we will see
some major companies recruiting sql
developers first we have
the multinational financial services
corporation
american express followed by the
multinational professional services
network
ernst and young we also have the
messaging company
whatsapp then we have the e-commerce
giant amazon
as well as the technology and computer
solutions company
dell finally in a list of companies we
have the multinational technology
company google
with that we have come to the end of
this session i hope
it was exciting and informative if you
liked it
please let us know in the comment
section below also do subscribe to our
channel
and stay tuned for more from simply
learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here